Why does the Crabfeeder's freaky mask look so
freakin' familiar? You're not imagining it —
here's the surprising connection the villain's
headgear has to "Game of Thrones." Spoilers ahead!
HBO's highly anticipated prequel series, "House of
the Dragon," is pulling in massive numbers for the
network, proving that viewers are happy to return
to the fantasy world of Westeros , and in droves.
One intriguing element of the show
thus far is its swift introduction
and then just-as-swift killing off of the
villainous Crabfeeder, aka Craghas Drahar.
"The Crabfeeder is packed by
powerful entities within the
Free Cities who wish to see Westeros weakened."
The masked, grayscale-afflicted baddie
served as the first major outside threat
to the Targaryen protagonists. However,
there's also something about him that
surprisingly connects Crabfeeder
directly to "Game of Thrones."
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Crabfeeder actor Daniel Scott-Smith talked
extensively about his time as the
character on "House of the Dragon."
Among the more interesting tidbits was Scott-Smith
confirming a cool detail about his character's
mask and its ties to a well-known "Game
of Thrones" cult: the Sons of the Harpy.
He told the outlet that he discussed the mask
with the director of Episodes 2 and 3, saying,
"We spoke about the idea of him being the first
person to wear this mask and it becoming iconic
and, therefore, it's built from that [for
'Game of Thrones']. Why is he wearing the
mask? How does he feel about that? It's a power
statement, so he's quite happy wearing it."
While this is a fascinating connection for
"House of the Dragon" to make to its parent show,
it obviously raises more questions than it
answers. What inspired the Sons of the Harpy
to start wearing masks modeled after the one
that Crabfeeder wore? Is he something of a
legendary figure for them, or does it have
some deeper, perhaps religious connotations?
And perhaps most importantly of all, will
the showrunners dive into this topic further,
or will it be saved for some other,
far-off spin-off series? Regardless,
it's still a big connection between the shows
that diehard fans will no doubt appreciate.
Daemon Targaryen kills Crabfeeder off-screen
in Episode 3, and the first serious outside
antagonist the family faces in "House of
the Dragon" is gone in the blink of an eye.
Scott-Smith told EW that he never
even met Matt Smith on the set,
and that it was bizarre to see
his own prosthetic corpse on TV.
"It's a strange experience [...] I don't think
many people would experience that normally,
but it was quite surreal. It was cool, though."
The Crabfeeder never speaks, but the
reappearance of the gold mask in "House
of the Dragon" helps visually signify that
this person is an enemy of the Targaryens,
just as the Sons of the Harpy were in "Game
of Thrones." Fans of the original series
will remember the resistance group as one
of Daenerys Targaryen's foes in Seasons 5
and 6. The group forms to combat
Daenerys and her new rule of Meereen.
The gold mask is a representation of The Harpy,
a gold figure with the head and torso of a woman
and the wings, tail, and legs of a bird. This was
a symbol of the slave masters in Slaver's Bay,
so why Crabfeeder would be wearing the
same mask is a bit of a question mark.
His armies are from the free cities, so perhaps
this gold mask is just a way for "House of
Dragon" to identify a foe of House Targaryen. Or,
perhaps, it was just something thrown in for "Game
of Thrones" stans. Daniel Scott-Smith admitted
that was a factor in his EW interview, saying,
"It was definitely a nod to that for, I guess, the
fans, because it's something familiar for them."